I have never been to the Golden Globes
and so I'm just curious I know that
there's dancing and well I don't know
that I would I would dance if especially
I would love watching other celebrities
dance I'd do that for a little bit and
then I would want to cut loose and they
can ask myself did you I actually am not
sure if there was anyone dancing but me
in my group I had my niece and nephew
there and and an Al Roker came over to
enter he does interviews at the parties
afterwards and they were playing I think
they were playing poison or something
and we started a dance-off and that was
that was an incredible moment there with
Al Roker and he kept saying are you
gonna stop I'm like I'm not no I'm gonna
keep dancing and they were filming us
and I don't know how long it went on but
I looked for it the next day and I
couldn't find it anywhere so it didn't
give ya al just says he's taping stuff
for NBC that's his trick he just has
constantly going into parties on the
come shoot in a segment for NBC and then
later on yeah you know you look for it
in ain't there yeah find it but I had to
ask my ass off I had a great time I
really really did it was nice to
celebrate yeah of course
[Applause]
you